Merry Christmas
90% of Americans that our November
Monmouth University poll say they plan
to celebrate Christmas down slightly
from 96 percent who gave that response
in a similar Gallup poll a quarter
century ago in a 2017 poll the Pew
Research Center suggested that the
nature of Christmas may be changing
driven in part by generational change in
the poll majorities of all age groups
felt that religious aspects of Christmas
were emphasized less than in the past
but older people were bothered more by
this than younger ones there is other
evidence of changing attitudes 42% of
Millennials
compared to 58 percent of boomers say
they plan to attend religious services
on Christmas Eve or Christmas stage 6
and 10 Millennials compared to 46
percent of boomers say it doesn't matter
to them whether merchants say Merry
Christmas or Happy Holidays
older people prefer Merry Christmas
politics aside more Americans find the
holiday season more enjoyable than
stressful compared to the rest of the
year and around 8 and 10 planned to
gather with family and friends on
Christmas are you celebrating Christmas
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI